Lisa coils here with gamespot i'm here
with simon at the payday 2 booth outside
the expo hall so what's new what do you
bring in a 3 we got this new DLC
expansion called the big bank which is
something that our fans have been
waiting for quite a while so we're
bringing a really a really big bank true
hi swear you you got these you know
these segments where you're supposed to
like bring drill parts and drill bits
and build a huge drill and get into a
huge vault and then carried it out
carried out you know bag my bag gold and
money and all that stuff and we we even
have a new feature called pre-planning
where you choose what kind of escape or
if you want to have inside you know
information or insight people inside the
bank that help you with like a mo extra
ammo or poisoned cake to poison like the
staff the guard staff and stuff like
that so people can play together and
choose that stuff together as and kind
of develop the plan together before they
go in and do that so I'm not I'm not as
familiar with the paintings but I do
know you know it was a huge deal when
payday 2 was announced people were going
crazy this is you quit the cult
following apparently but so tell me for
people who don't know very much grew up
again kind of it could explain it a
little bit for me yeah you play four
people together and you're robbers you
hit the armored transports and banks and
that kind of stuff and just raw people
blind cooperative on playstation 3 xbox
360 and PC you explain me a character's
a little bit I see these awesome masks
on the wall those intrigued me yeah we
have four four characters in the game
hoxton chains Dallas and Wolf they all
got their own mess and their own
personalities and voices in the game
and they're guided by a guy called bein
who's actually voiced by myself oh my
gosh so cool bit about that identify
acting in games two and I absolutely
love it how was it like for you kind of
bringing that character to life well we
just made sure that I mean he's detached
from the rest of the gang he's not there
maybe he's sitting in some office
somewhere or in some van like a few
blocks away so he's kind of detached
from from the action so we made sure
that he's very calm he doesn't get upset
while the robbers world more like oh we
need to do this and they're more like
hectic and then panicked and bring more
of I think what the players feel like
reflecting what the players feel when
they're dying and when they're when
things are going well would you totally
kill me if I asked for a line of
dialogue give us a line of dialogue just
give me a sample from the game uh I
gotta get into the he's up here honey so
you're putting me on the spot now uh um
keep them hell nice I like it I like it
can you kind of show me what's going on
in in this booth here there's some crazy
sometimes ago the microphone feel like
I'm competing with him right now but you
sure you can you show me around yeah we
got we got 12 years ok tomorrow
computers so we got three groups who can
play together for people together on
these 12 stations and they're all
playing an e3 exclusive version of the
big bank the new heist will be released
on Tuesday next week we've just shorten
it down a bit because it's much more
complicated advanced and it takes much
more time than we have time to let
people play here at e3 in the normal
version so the e3 version is a bit
shorter and like you said via the DLC is
going to be pretty much just a
continuation on from the story of payday
2 just kind of you know still still in
that same story yeah and it's a contract
giving to you as a player by the dentist
which is a new contact that you get
missions or heists heist ideas or
highest orders from
okay what is going on in this cage back
here there's like this flashing lights
kind of give me a seizure I like it if
if a group of four players actually get
inside the vault we let them step inside
one of the fort step inside that box and
grab as many $100 payday bills as
possible in 30 seconds and then they can
win prizes yeah what are the bills that
you you earn them and then you you guys
give them cool stuff cool swag yeah
exactly depending on how many how many
bills you get you can get like masks and
t-shirts with with the characters on if
you get like a golden or bronze or
silver bill you can get some extra stuff
that like we have a Titan graphics cards
and we have some other really really
nice prizes how many people have been in
there so far I've been occupy you know
guiding people through the game so I
haven't actually seen by maybe five six
people may even in there have you tried
to and the show hasn't even opened yet
oh it's true oh well thank you so much
for talking to me thoughts on the new
DLC tweet me at least flows tweet at
gamespot with the hashtag gamespot III